joining us now trump campaign senior
advisor and daughter-in-law to the
president laura trump lara
welcome back to fox news sunday thank
you great to be with you chris
let's start with the president's health
his doctor put out a memo yesterday that
said this
he is no longer considered a
transmission risk to others
but it doesn't say that he tested
negative laura
is your father-in-law now free
of the coronavirus is it gone
well according to the white house
medical staff
it sounds like that's the answer
obviously
working at the campaign we do not
conduct any testing on him ourselves
so if the white house doctor says that
he is free of transmission
i think that that sounds like he's he's
done with the coronavirus and uh
by all accounts he should be able to go
out get back on the road campaigning he
certainly
should be able to do a debate on october
15th but we know the debate commission
decided against that they wanted it
virtual but it sounds by all accounts
like he is
free of the coronavirus
okay we'll get to the debate in a moment
uh as we said just a moment ago the
president held an event
on the south lawn of the white house
yesterday and while
people were not socially distanced uh
many but not all were wearing masks
having said that that's a lot better
than two weeks ago
at the event for judge amy coney barrett
where people were packed in almost no
masks
and dr fauci has said that that event
was a super spreader question why did it
take
the president getting coveted for the
white house to take the cdc
safety guidelines more seriously
although even yesterday they were still
violating some
well at that amy coney barrett event
look i think most of those people if not
all of those people
were tested for coronavirus before
sitting down for that event
and you'd never hear chris on the other
side of the coin
the fact that we have had in this
country since
really the height of the the covid days
these
demonstrations across america riots in
the streets
peaceful protests some of them many of
them not peaceful
all across america but you never hear
any concern
after these things about those being
super spreader events i have yet to hear
one doctor say anything about them i
have yet to hear one media outlet
say anything about those it doesn't seem
like coronavirus would have a political
agenda but
oftentimes it feels like it does because
those events are never
talked about as being an issue so look
the white house has always followed
guidelines they've always
either tested people before they're
around the president
or whenever there's not testing
available for the number of people that
are there
encourage people to wear masks and and
honestly if we all look at this from
from the same perspective it doesn't
seem right that we're
criticizing one event and not another
well i i take your point about the
protest but that doesn't make what
happened
at the white house which as i say tony
fauci says
was a super spreader at least eight
people at that event later came down
with the virus including the president
and the first lady i got to ask you
because you were there about another
event which was the first
debate 12 days ago in cleveland uh
the the cleveland clinic's rules were
very clear
everyone in the audience had to wear a
mask but after the first family came in
with mass you all
took them off did you think lara
that the rules that applied to everybody
else in that hall
didn't apply to you well of course we
didn't think that and first of all i'll
say that
everyone in there chris was tested and
tested negative
for for covid at least in our family
before we even
got on the plane to to head out to
cleveland
um and we walked in with the mast on we
sat down all of the the seats were
socially distanced
and i've heard you actually say this
many times i want to be very clear
never one time did anyone from cleveland
clinic come up and ask
any member of our family to put a mask
on so
that is totally false i know that that
notion has been out there that is not
true
we were respectful to people around us
coming in we wanted to to
do that to walk in with the mass on we
sat down we didn't move from those seats
until the very end until it was all over
and uh and we felt like we were being
safe those are the same guidelines
applied to restaurants those are the
same guidelines applied to
to many uh outlets across america and
the fact that we had tested
negative chris i mean you know look we
we followed the rules
that as we thought that they were given
to us
well i don't want to belabor this i'm
going to move on but
the everybody in that hall had tested
negative i
had had a test three days before you
couldn't get in the hall
without testing negative and and the
fact is the rules were
everybody except for the president the
vice president and i
were supposed to wear masks and it was
the pool report i'm not just making this
up
the pool report says that a member of
the cleveland clinic and in fact there's
video that exists
coming up to somebody in the
presidential party and saying would you
like masks and they were waved away
well they didn't ask any member of our
family i i what i understood afterwards
is that colby covington who was sitting
behind me
had a maga mask on and they didn't
appreciate that apparently so
i think they were coming up to offer him
maybe a different mask that's all i can
tell you about it but
never once chris was anybody from our
family asked to put a mask on
i want to ask you about some of the
president's actions
this week on tuesday he tweeted
this i'm going to put it up on the
screen i have instructed my
representatives
to stop negotiating on covid relief
until after the election walking away
from talks with nancy pelosi by friday
the president was saying this
i would like to see a bigger stimulus
package frankly than either the
democrats or the republicans are
offering i'm going in the exact opposite
now okay
how could the president go in three days
from
saying that the top offer was what 1.6
trillion
to on friday three days later saying he
wanted to do more than nancy pelosi's
2.4 trillion
which now republicans are rejecting as
far too much
well i think first and foremost let's
point out the fact that i think most
people
can agree nancy pelosi was not serious
about this negotiation
this was a liberal wish list as have
they all been
uh when it comes to these these stimulus
bills uh with nancy
you know defunding the police bail out
money for states that were
in huge deficits well before
covid hit any of them trying to bail
them out for their bad decision making
from democrat
uh governors and and look the president
is entitled to change his mind i haven't
specifically talked to him
about this but you know maybe he got
some different information i can tell
you chris
the bottom line is that he wants what is
best for the american people
you saw the way he pushed forward the
paycheck protection program
in the middle of coba to make sure that
small businesses could stay
afloat that people could weather the
storm this is no different he
understands that there are people out
there
who desperately need this money but it
feels like the democrats and nancy
pelosi
are yet again playing politics and that
is not what we need right now
uh i got one last question we got one
last minute to talk about it when the
commission on
presidential debates announced this week
that it was going to change the the
debate that as you mentioned has come it
was supposed to come up
on thursday the 15th from in person a
town hall to a virtual
town hall the president immediately
pulled out
that debate has now been cancelled
i understand why the president would
have preferred an in-person debate but
that wasn't what was on the table
didn't he make a mistake regardless of
what you think of the commission
didn't the president make a mistake
because he's now lost one of his
last two chances to confront joe biden
on camera well i don't think so look i
think a virtual
debate is is just a complete disaster
quite frankly
we see even now when we're talking
there's a delay uh
in in communication this is how it goes
virtually you cannot have
a legitimate debate with somebody
virtually
and i know look who's to say what
happens on the other end of things what
happens on the trump side what happens
on the binding side
nobody knows these two men should be on
stage
there is no reason that they shouldn't
be 175 doctors told the new york post
that they think that the president
without a doubt should have been able to
do this it made no sense
um and good for the president for
calling it out why did the debate
commission chris
decide early on no we're not going to
add a fourth debate like the
trump campaign was pushing for because
they didn't want to change the rules
they told us
now they're willing to change the rules
without reaching out to our campaign
made a split second decision the day
after the vice president had a very
strong debate against kamala harris
it seems a little suspect to people and
i think a virtual debate is an
absolute disaster good for the president
for saying no they need to be in person
lara thank you thanks for your time this
weekend always good to talk with you and
happy birthday tomorrow
thank you and happy birthday to you as
well